let's get into the business of why
you're here drag con NYC is coming back
yes second year second one I am like the
expert of dry calm because I've been to
every single one because the first drag
con was I think four years ago it was my
season season seven is the first year of
the drag calm so I remember when it was
our first hurrah
and now to see what it is I mean it
seems like every year the tenants like
doubles triples it's crazy
just cuz y'all fun drag con is clearly
people are going once and going I'm
going again and I'm bringing five
friends what are your tips and tricks to
having a successful drag con if you're
going as a fan of drag I think I'm like
an expert on this first of all let me
talk to you about this show I know this
is a disgusting shoe I know that this
length in this height of this heel is
kind of unacceptable but I'm telling you
if you wear some strappy crazy
disgusting stiletto fantasy an hour into
walking around on this concrete floor
and there's overhead lighting you're
gonna be walking around barefoot wishing
you like we're leaving so I could
experience people bring like a slip on
to walk around in and then a heel for
the photos with the drag queens there we
go definitely bring like some sort of
like snack you want to say raw almonds
you want to honey perhaps maybe yeah
maybe oh yeah oh honey yeah exactly
hairspray oh you want to bring look at a
pat if you're wearing a wig make sure
you bring extra bobby pin what I do I
take a bunch of extra hair pins and I
stick them in the nape of my wig oh
where nobody can see him so then if I
have a problem I just reach in grab and
fix what's your favorite thing about
drag con um to be perfectly honest my
favorite thing I just I get such a kick
out of it like one year pheromone was
setting up and I was looking at her
booth it was balloons and it said eff a
ra H and I was like rebranding she was
like my funny sad yeah back into one and
it's fun to like last year I was in line
and there was I mean people always come
dressed as Trixie but then this girl
came in she was like maybe four and she
was dressed as IQ kitty and seeing kids
dressed as drag queens it's pretty
surreal I mean I'm not a child fan but I
mean they're they're around I
acknowledge that they are
but I'm not like you know I'm not
looking to touch I will say accompanying
my tips to your comfort at droidcon
definitely know that drag is never
consent don't touch drag queens don't
touch don't I mean if you touch a drag
queens hair I think just go straight to
hell and be be prepared to have a friend
this is like the drag queen trick if
you're in like conference room lighting
you get that hater friend to take your
picture and then you get your other
friend your hype man to put their flash
on and hold it oh you don't want your
one picture with like Naomi smalls to be
like dim overhead lighting you know you
know yeah you want this lighting
yes exactly or just bring all these
studio lights yes just bring this setup
that you can't see at home but we have a
large setup yeah we're gonna jack on but
know what that'll go unnoticed
inconspicuous totally and if you want to
turn a look I think just turn a look
with comfort in mind maybe this is the
day you turn a kaftan
maybe this is the day you turn a you
know wrap dress don't try don't do too
much you're he's so unhappy at droidcon
I mean for me drag Cohn like in New York
this year it's gonna be Friday Saturday
and Sunday you want to think okay maybe
Friday I will shop because I don't want
things to be sold out and maybe Saturday
I'll commit the morning to waiting in
line to meet oneexchange
and then maybe Saturday night I'll go to
a panel so like you also want to plan
what you're doing you don't want to get
there and just have like overload right
don't do a free-for-all go in with a
plan yep
so have your kit of like safety pins
bobby pins yep and a snack and a maybe a
flask yep come win with a plan and dress
comfortably a yard come to dry con
prepared in the way like a Caucasian mom
from Minnesota might go couponing like I
have a binder and the otter bottle you
know like comfortable shoes and for the
first drag con ever RuPaul's gonna be
out on the floor she is yeah one year
like you never actually to see a track
on it's kind of like Disney in that way
where things I just pop up and happen
one year RuPaul roller skated through
drag Club that's a sight to see I know
she's already like six seven on a drag
so it's just this avatar in fashionable
sunglasses gliding through a Convention
Center and you're like where am I
you're at Drakon yeah when you're RuPaul
got on the UM like that the the PA thing
and she was just like good afternoon
hookers
well that's three Paul's God voice of
God yeah call me a hooker and especially
I've just be prepared to sort of budget
your time I mean some of these you might
have to wait an hour to to meet somebody
it really matters to you but then you
can go get a corn dog and rest your feet
it's a mix of highs lows all weekend
long it's like this if the State Fair
happened at a gay club that's the
perfect description put on a tag line TM
copy